one of the things I've learned as a
doctor on Tik Tok is how many people are
going to the doctor and just being told
to lose weight now I have always known
trust me that weight can be a source of
Shame and stigma and something that
actually stops people from going to the
doctor because they want to go get help
with their problems but they don't want
to be weighed they don't want to get a
lecture on how they need to lose weight
especially when they're things that have
nothing to do with their weight and
people want to avoid that lecture on
weight loss when they just want help
with their nausea or something I may not
be doctor myself but I'm pretty sure
that if you are struggling with nausea
your weight could have everything to do
with it well it all comes from eating
too much in fact pretty much any ailment
involving your stomach or your digestive
tract can be caused or exacerbated by
obesity you want your belt to buckle not
your chair also any ailment involving
your internal organs or your bones or
your heart or any other part of your
body can be caused or exacerbated by
obesity